[Musique]
vous
pendant qu ont changé de position on a
été repéré par un drone est bombardé
on a pris soin des blessés
et pendant que j'étais en train
d'évacuer l'un de mes frères d'armes
j'ai été touché à 28 ans victor fait
partie des forces spéciales
l'ukrainienne en mai son unité a subi de
lourdes pertes
[Musique]
on a eu neuf blessés deux morts et cinq
ont subi une commotion cérébrale grave
je ne peux pas dire que je souffre de ce
que j'ai vu
sicaud logiquement ça va c'est juste que
je me sens inutile malicieuse
comme victor la plupart des 200 patients
de cet hôpital sont des combattants
blessés souffrent ils y séjournent en
moyenne trois semaines après avoir été
stabilisés à l'origine l'établissement
avait pour mission d'aider les vétérans
du donbass à se réinsérer dans la vie
civile depuis l'agression plus de
février sa priorité à changer
notre objectif principal c'est d'aider
les combattants à se remettre de leurs
blessures de leur traumatisme
comme ça on peut ramener le plus de
soldats possible à leurs activités à
leur service ce sont nos priorités nous
devons restaurer leurs forces et leurs
ressources morales et les rendre à
nouveau prêt au combat
en mars dernier oleksandr à participer à
une violente bataille impliquant tanks
et infanterie dans la région de donetsk
il a été blessé à la jambe même s'il
n'exclut pas un retour au front cette
perspective est encore lointaine
n'a pas de chat
juste après l'explosion j'étais en très
mauvais état
je bégayais mais ça ça va mieux
mais mon sommeil est perturbé je me
réveille plusieurs fois par nuit parce
que je ne peux pas respirer
je souffre de cauchemars je rêve que je
suis survolée par des avions je me
réveille en sursaut et en âge
physiquement je pense que je peux m'en
remettre mais psychologiquement je n'en
suis pas sûr
dans cet hôpital spécialisé dans les
stress post traumatique relaxation et
l'acupuncture font partie du programme
les soignants sont attentifs à la
singularité des chocs neurologiques subi
dans les combats
donc pour pas chaude c'est
d'abord on traite beaucoup de commotions
cérébrales parce que c'est une guerre
d'artillerie on appelle ça les blessures
invisibles de la guerre
deuxièmement il n'est pas normal pour la
psyché humaine de participer à une
action militaire
en général ils commencent à voir tout
noir ou tout blanc
c'est commun pour les soldats ils ne
perçoivent plus les 10 ans du monde
politique
retrouver ses repères et plus délicat
pour les civils aspiré dans le conflit
au début de la guerre oleksy 36 ans
s'est envolé dans la défense
territoriale
cet homme là il est mort
son traitement comporte des sciences de
smt stimulation magnétique
transcrânienne
détendez vous
on utilise la smt pour traiter l'anxiété
la dépression les bégaiements provoquées
par des traumatismes
[Musique]
je n'avais pas d'expérience militaire
j mais j'étais préparée physiquement
jeu pratiqué les arts martiaux
l'autodéfense le paintball et l'airsoft
très vite olexi a été déployé dans une
unité de reconnaissance au commandement
militaire et s'est retrouvé en première
ligne
quand il ya un orage le lot n'arrête pas
de tomber c'était la même chose avec les
missiles et les roquettes
c'était amusant
ma mission consistait à évacuer des
personnes étudiées
et gelé réalisée à 100%
plus tard j'ai découvert que j'avais une
bombe psychologique dans ma tête et j'ai
décidé de faire une pause un pas de côté
je suis heureux d'être complètement
opérationnelle
je peux marcher manger entendre respirer
c'est une chance de revenir vivant j'ai
l'opportunité de vivre d'aimer de
travailler pourquoi ne pas saisir cette
opportunité pour avancer
en juin mois d'intenses combats les
autorités ukrainiennes déclaré que 500
soldats étaient blessés chaque jour
leurs cicatrices vont marquer le pays
pendant des années